this talk is based on a series of
articles for a list of part um
eponymously named uh which is this sort
of collection of ideas and techniques
about getting javascript performance
under control but it's wrapped in a
in a philosophy and the philosophy is
let's just try to use javascript a
little bit more responsibly a little
more thoughtfully
um so if you like this talk you might
like these articles there's two parts uh
i want to get two more parts done this
year
um so if you want to find them
uh links will be in the slide deck and
it will be posted to noticed
when i'm done no tist which is an
awesome speaker tool so
um i'll post it to twitter okay so to
start this off i want to talk about a
word that i stumbled on
years ago called speciousness which is
an
unusual word that has some relevance to
our work
and to be specious means to exhibit
these sort of deterministic or
pre-programmed behaviors you know think
of like
things that aren't willful behaviors
they're kind of just automatic things
that
that are done right and so the root word
specs is a name for a genus of solitary
wasps
and i promise you that the organizers
didn't stick an entomology talk
in the middle of a javascript conference
we'll get to the javascript don't worry
it's it's a whole thing
so these wasps don't just act in a
pre-programmed fashion
they're also really easily manipulated
and that's part of what makes them
specious
um and the way that they're specious is
is when wasps
provision their larva which they usually
give them crickets
they'll bring the prey back to the nest
and they begin this routine
and before dragging the cricket into the
nest the wasp will leave it outside and
then it will go back in
to inspect the nest and this behavior
seems thoughtful but it really isn't
because if an observer
moves the cricket it will set the cr
if before if the observer removes uh
moves the cricket before the wasp
re-emerges
uh it will set the cricket back to where
it was before and then go back in and
inspect the nest again and you literally
could do this
endlessly you could just do this over
and over and over again and the wasp
will never catch on
so i didn't come to omaha to be a big
jerk and imply that you're all mindless
um we're thoughtful web developers are
thoughtful people
but there are some decisions involved in
our work and i'm guilty of this too
that we make without question and for
example or an example of this
when we begin a new project we open a
terminal window and we install
a familiar framework and then possibly
a client-side router for the framework
and then possibly
a state management library for the
framework of course
and all the while we're kind of unaware
or have even
made peace with the overhead that these
conveniences bring
they're conveniences that help us to do
our work um
but they have a direct and felt impact
this matters because the amount of
javascript
that we serve is steadily increased over
the years to the point where it has
become
in my opinion probably the top
performance concern in most websites
uh certainly something my clients run
into and half the sites you visit will
send 375k or less
of javascript the 75th percentile will
send at least 650
and the 90th percentile meaning 10 of
websites out there will send
at least one megabyte of javascript and
these graphs are generated from the http
archive which among other things
tracks the transfer size transfer
size of javascript which is often
compressed
while compression is essential to
loading performance it doesn't change
the fact that when a
megabyte of compressed javascript is
sent over the wire
the browser decompresses it to probably
three times as much depending on your
compression ratio
and that is a significantly large bundle
that browsers must parse
compile and execute and that takes time
and if you're using a high-end
device on a fast network you probably
won't feel how slow this can be
but on less capable hardware such as
this affordable
but much much slower moto g4 android
phone chewing through tons of javascript
is a real slog and that's worth paying
attention to
because when devices or networks or both
are slow using the web becomes more
difficult
and at the bottom of this web page test
timeline is a main thread activity
indicator and when it's red the browser
can't do
anything else just can't do anything
else and when it's green
it can like take on other tasks and you
can see here for two
four sometimes six seconds at a time the
main thread is blocked with all the
scripting activity which is indicated in
yellow there is some render stuff in
there but it's mostly scripts
you pair this with a slow network on a
slow device you can imagine how
tiresome the web really can be for a lot
of people
and so understanding constraints is is a
key
to writing good software the best video
games ever made were a megabyte
under that usually sometimes far less
some video games were like within
a megabit 128k uh game developers of the
time not only had
vision but they also understood the
constraints on their work
but their constraints were fixed to the
hardware that they produced systems for
if you made a super nintendo game your
constraints were so static it was anyone
who has a super nintendo
that was it uh but our constraints are
far from fixed they're very different
from person to person
and in some ways that makes our job much
more difficult than theirs but that
doesn't mean that we can't make great
experiences on the web that work for
everyone everywhere or even
you know make them without javascript
like we can use javascript but we just
have to think a little bit more about
what we can do to get just a little bit
faster
so let's talk about how we can turn that
speciousness into
anti-speciousness for the good of the
web and for all who use it
so there's this cool phrase i came
across recently it goes
paint the picture not the frame and it
comes from an article by eric bailly
on a list apart about accessibility in
ux
and it's a clever way of saying that we
really shouldn't reinvent things that
the browser already does well
like buttons and forms and all this
other you know stuff that we rely on
that we often paper over with javascript
sometimes
and eric in his article advises us that
we should not subvert a person's
expectations by changing externally
consistent behaviors
examples of external consistency might
be
default behaviors of html elements or
the appearance of a scroll bar
even because when we disrupt these
things when we disrupt
disrupt external consistency we may
impede people in ways we didn't expect
or they didn't expect
and one way we do this is when we fail
to use semantic html
and instead rely on javascript to
re-implement or approximate those
behaviors
and this can result in websites which
are harder to use for those who rely on
assistive technology let's take this
example react component
which is a newsletter subscription form
and this component has an input field a
corresponding label
and a submit button and it's all in a
single div and you may have some
opinions on what's wrong here
but the solution doesn't require more
javascript it actually requires
less so let's dive into this jsx real
quick
there are three things wrong here one
a form isn't a form unless it's in a
form
tag and tiffs are not intrinsically
flawed
they they lack semantic meaning by
design but this is a
form a form should always use a form tag
because that has meaning to those on
assistive technology
and two when we label inputs a label
element should be used with a four
attribute that corresponds to an id on
the input
and this lets assistive technology know
that a given input has an associated
label and that's not just for people who
are
less able they actually make forms
easier to interact with for everybody
because you can click on the label and
it will focus the field
and three while divs can be coded to
behave and look like buttons
doing so robs the button of any semantic
meaning it would otherwise have if it
was just a
button a button element think of that
huh
and plus a button element's default
behavior within a form is to submit that
form that means it's more resilient
for when not if javascript fails because
your javascript's going to fail to run
somewhere so here's the refactored
markup with all that
advice of which every part now has
semantic meaning that assistive
technologies can use
and assuming the component is server
rendered it will also continue to work
if the scripts fail to run and now note
that the submit event handler
has moved from the buttons on click
event to the forms on submit event
this is helpful for when we want to
intercept a forms submit event if we
want to enhance this form's behavior
with client-side scripts later on
now here's the final component code
additionally because the email
validation is now handled through html
we can remove the email validation
script entirely because we're using an
email input type with a required
attribute
so we're relying on the browser to
validate those things for us
but of course you should always sanitize
your inputs in the server but this is an
opportunity to send
less client-side code and any
opportunity where you can remove some
client-side script and get
things a little bit lighter should be
like just joyous you know like
throw it away if you don't like it throw
it away so external consistency
isn't limited to html and css and
javascript we expect
browsers themselves to behave in a
predictable way
and one of the most common subversions
of this predictability is
the spa or the single page application
don't throw things at me yet i don't
hate sbas bye
the navigation behavior they replace is
one that browsers already do very well
even if it's synchronous and so when we
embrace client-side routing we take on a
whole host of new responsibilities that
we didn't have to think about before
because the browser managed it for us
history must be managed you have to
account for scrolling position and tab
index uh navigation canceling can fail
there's just a whole bunch of stuff that
this specified behavior that you have to
think about
and even if even if we get client-side
routing perfect performance is affected
if that content is not server rendered
and furthermore when we fail to send
contentful markup from the server
the page's contents will be inaccessible
if
javascript fails somehow and so when we
rely on standard synchronous navigation
behavior
we do lose a degree of snappiness but we
retain that external consistency
that people have come to expect that's
not to say that client-side routers are
always bad dirty dirty filthy things
but using them requires extra care on
your part
and for example um you'll need to apply
you'll need to provide
server-side equivalence to all of your
client-side routes so that people have a
way to reliably access that content
uh from any context whether it's from
within your site or from google or like
a
site link from somewhere else and then
if components are attached to
server-side markup through client-side
hydration
people get a progressively enhanced
experience and that's where the really
special [ __ ] is
so sorry if you
if you want to avoid sbas but want to
make navigation snappier
and you want to rely on a sort of
platform provided solution
link prefetching may fit the bill for
you it can seriously boost
loading performance by fetching page
html in advance of the user requesting
it
it's not perfect you could potentially
waste data if it's not done carefully
but to address these potential
shortcomings the google chrome team
offers a
very small link prefetching script like
teeny tiny
it will only prefetch links as they
appear in the viewport using an
intersection observer
when the main thread is idle and if the
network isn't slow
so i know i'm getting my prattling on
about all the free stuff the browser
gives us but the point remains the
browser gives us a lot for free
so let's use that stuff whenever
possible so we can focus on the harder
problems of web development another
tenet of my responsible javascript
philosophy consists of
what i consider to be a fundamental
truth that we need to acknowledge which
is that
the tools are not infallible
a hammer can help you build something or
it can break all your fingers
you have to understand how the tools
work and that knowing that is a part of
creating fast and accessible websites
you can't just assume that the tools do
the hard work for you or do everything
optimally for you
and one tool many of us use that when we
need the javascript we write to work
everywhere is babel
babel is valuable but we tend not to see
how it can harm performance
we would all benefit if we could
transpile less
because the way babel transforms our
code can add a lot to our production
bundles
and it helps to know how babel
transforms the kobe right so we can
compensate for its inefficiencies
so here's an example of a it's just sort
of a very simple example of an example
like kind of console logging wrapper
function which accepts message and level
parameters and the second parameter is
the log level
which has a default of log so like you
know that's the console method log warn
error default parameters are nice
but babel transforms them very
inefficiently and
worse yet it repeats that inefficient
transform every time the default
parameter is used
just to accommodate that developer
experience that you wanted to use
that gets passed on to the user so if we
can't avoid babel altogether we should
try to compensate for this stuff
so in this particular case we can avoid
this specific transform
by replacing the default parameter with
an or check and when we want to assign a
default to an optional parameter
we can check we can perform a check
where the left side of the or is the
parameter itself that's provided by the
user or by us
rather and the right side is the default
and if the level parameter is omitted
the right side of the or condition is
used and babel will not touch this
it won't transform it but that's not the
only thing babel transforms
default parameters are just one such
feature uh let's
take yes es6 classes as another example
i like them they're nice they kind of
make classes as you know
they resemble like like classes that
we've seen in other languages
but the way babel transforms them
is really expensive uh just to get this
to work everywhere
um and if you can't read it that's fine
that's kind of the point it's a lot of
extra code
you can mitigate this cost in one of a
few ways you could use the prototype
pattern
and avoid es6 classes all together for
those platforms that need this transform
you could use babel plug-in transform
runtime to de-duplicate
this helper that babel uses to reduce
the impact across an entire project
or three if you only need to support
modern browsers you could drop babel
altogether
if you can do this it's your best bet
but if you're using like something like
jsx you're probably never going to be
able to drop it
how we write javascript though is isn't
the only thing to consider when we're
using babel we also need to configure
babel as well like configure it itself
and so here's an example webpack bundle
analysis for an example app
which uses a babel configuration that
isn't finely tuned
and it sits at about 117 kilobytes and
you'll notice most of it is comprised of
polyfills
poly polyfilling is something we use
babel a lot for
um it's useful it helps us to kind of
like fill in those missing gaps for a
lot of the you know things that we write
for older browsers and if you're
familiar with babel presetm
this configuration code may look a
little familiar but it is worth taking a
second look at that use built-ins option
uh which uses core js to polyfill
features
so when use built-ins is set to entry
core js
itself must be added as an entry point
to the project
which adds more polyfills than we might
need
but if we change the value of used
built-ins from entry to
usage we can remove corejs as an entry
point in the app
and babel will only polyfill the
features that are actually
used in our code that are appropriate
for those specified platforms
this can seriously reduce how many
polyfills get used
and while we're here there's another
option i think that deserves some
attention
which toggles something called loose
mode which is when babel transforms your
code
loosely this means that babel's output
adheres
less strictly to the ecmascript standard
loose transforms are
a bit smaller and or quite a bit i've
seen projects
reduced by 10 simply by enabling this
and they can be enabled by setting the
loose option to true and babel preset m
but it's not bulletproof you could have
issues if you move from transpiled es6
um to untranspiled es6 later on if you
remove babel but if the savings are
worth it you can always address this in
a sprint if the problem comes up so you
can retain your gains
and after making these two quick
configuration changes
we reduce the size of this bundle by 52
and that's a big deal with half as much
code this app will be faster especially
for devices with limited processing
power
and less memory in addition
to all these little configuration tips
and hacks
a novel way of serving less javascript
today is a hobby horse of mine
but it's been a thing for about the last
year it's called differential serving
which involves serving one of two
bundles to users based on the capability
of their browser
and legacy what this means is that
legacy browsers will get bundles like we
generate them today with more transforms
and polyfills while modern browsers will
get
smaller bundles with little to none of
those things and the outcome is that
an app functions identically in either
case but for modern browsers it involves
substantially less
code so of course we need a way to load
these bundles properly and what you see
here
is how we've always loaded javascript
pretty straightforward
the pattern shown here is how we can
differentially serve scripts and so that
in here the first script tag loads a
bundle for modern browsers
uh by adding a type equals module
attribute which ensures that this script
gets picked up by those browsers
uh the second script element loads a
bundle for legacy browsers
no module ensures that modern browsers
will decline to download the legacy
script it just goes no i'm not going to
touch that
all right but legacy browsers don't
understand no module
so they will download this script anyway
configuring your tool chain to do this
is involved but it is doable uh it's
kind of like you have to fork your
configurations from the same
entry point and so it starts with
creating two different babel
configurations um
first uh this configuration is sort of
typical
of what you'd see in a lot of projects
which transform code that's compatible
everywhere including old browsers
but now this is a configuration for
generating bundles for modern browsers
and you'll notice that use built-ins is
gone and the reason for that
is because in this particular example
app we didn't need any of the polyfills
for core js because
we're using stuff that the modern
platform provides
but depending on the language features
or other features you use you may need
to retain use built-ins
instead of a browser's list query we've
supplied an option named es module set
to true
which under the hood this translates to
a browser's list query
for browsers that support es6 modules
and what's great about this
is that if a browser supports es6
modules we can infer
a lot of other things that it supports
like async weight
latin const arrow functions all that
stuff and so forth
so we can group these configs together
under an env object in our babel config
and so client legacy is the config for
legacy browsers while client
modern is a config for modern ones and
then in our bundler config
we can point to these separate
configurations and in webpack this is a
typical
typical example of how babel loader
ensures that scripts get processed by
babel
now note the env name option which
points to the babel configs that we've
specified in the uh
in the previous slide and by creating a
separate
webpack config and pointing to the
client modern babble config you can
generate a smaller bundle of your code
for modern browsers with identical
functionality and that's important
because you don't sacrifice any features
for this
it's all gained from here it's all gains
and so the size reduction between these
bundles really depends
sometimes you might only get five to ten
percent but some projects could see more
i've seen some components for clients
that can be reduced as much as 40
percent in some cases
and so this is a bundle analysis of an
of the same example app
legacy bundle which is pretty small
around 68k
but with differential serving we can go
from small to nano and deliver this app
to modern browsers and 40
of the size of its legacy counterpart
without sacrificing
anything it works identically but beware
some browsers may have
issues with this platform provided
pattern remember type equals module and
no module
um there's a lot about it and i can't
cover it in this talk but
i have an article here on my website at
jeremy.cods
uh that kind of explains it and it gives
a workaround that i've been able to use
in production for
for a fairly prominent electronics
retailer
and so it's been battle tested and it is
working
and it doesn't have any of the issues
described in the article
finally this leads us into a discussion
about what it means to be
accommodating and this is sort of my
favorite part of the talk because it
gets away from like
the real techy parts of javascript that
can be kind of fatiguing and talks a
little bit more about
adapting to people which is something
that i really is really kind of a hobby
horse of mine
because i feel that when we deploy
something to the web
we have to kind of be a steward of that
thing right like we kind of have to
you know we kind of have to be the
gatekeeper to like say this is
this is how this should be maintained
and we should keep our users
uh at the top of mind so in the u.s
and this is relevant because in the u.s
many people live in large cities work
which are typically well
served by fast broadband and mobile
internet connections
yet this article by the mit technology
review revealed that 58
of households in the cleveland
metropolitan area with yearly incomes
under 20
000 had no broadband internet access
these are people who rely on mobile
internet connections to do that work
and those usually come with data caps
and some of them come with overages
not all of them are unlimited it just
depends on your provider
and more striking to me is this passage
in which pew research found that
one-third of americans
do not have an internet connection in
their homes that are faster
that's faster than dial up i doubt i
sincerely doubt
um since this article was written in
2016 that
the that the picture has really gotten
much better
and the reason why is because the
economic and infrastructure challenges
that
people face and that we all face have
not been sufficiently addressed to
broaden
uh broadband access for everyone so if
you're serving a lot of assets
high latency or low bandwidth can make
your site functionally inaccessible to a
large group of people
and thankfully a technology called
client hints which is supported in
chrome
and derived browsers um edges chromium
now and basically anything that's blink
derived which is a huge chunk of the web
will support this
can help us bridge this divide so client
hints help
help developers to understand the
characteristics or at least the
approximate characteristics
of a person's device and the network
it's connected to
there's a lot of client hints there's
probably at least 10 of them
but i don't have time for all that i did
do a talk about it last year and i wrote
a big article which i'll show you or
link
in here but here are three that i feel
are the most useful
the first is rtt or round trip time
which is the approximate latency of a
user's connection in milliseconds
downlink is the approximate downstream
bandwidth in kilobits per second
and the next is ect or effective
connection type which is an
enumerated string that categorizes the
user's connection
based on both the rtt and downlink hints
it sort of tries to coarsely
categorize a user's connection to like
into very like coarse buckets 4g
3g 2g that sort of thing
um these hints really help us to
understand people
and what their what their situation is
like
and that can help us tailor experiences
so that we send less stuff
to those on slow connections we can opt
into these hints with the accept ch
request header you could set that in
like a meta http equiv
or on the server in whatever function
you use in a language to set
uh request headers um and we can also
uh tell the client how long we want
those hints to persist
with the accept ch lifetime header it's
sort of like
um how long they should be available
sort of like a caching directive but for
these hints it doesn't catch the value
of those hints just
the hints that we want so in this above
example
the rtt downlink and ect hints will
persist on the client for one day
then you can access these hints as
request headers via a server side
language
so here for example in php don't throw
things at me that's
the one i use um uh we initialize a
variable with the default
effective connection type of 4g because
not all browsers support client hints so
we want to assume
the ideal experience we want to assume a
fast connection
um but if client hints are available
we can check for that ect header and if
it's been set
and you know we can read it we can
overwrite that variable with that value
so then we can get an idea of what the
user's connection is
if they support client hints and so with
that information
we can create lighter experiences for
those who need it most
for example we can decide that a person
will only see a carousel if they're on a
fast connection
otherwise we compensate by sending them
only what they really need like the
critical
core content that people actually need
and i call this adaptive performance and
it's
a way to create experiences that i feel
are
not just more adaptable but more
inclusive like it gets people
like it broadens access for people a
little bit by being aware of the
shifting network conditions
you know that people run into and not
just shifting network conditions could
be device conditions
uh there are uh there's a hint for
example for how much memory a device has
which we can use and decide well if it's
a low-power device maybe we
should try cutting a little bit of
script because that's memory intensive
and it works um here are two versions of
the same site the left
is the unclient hintified version and
the right is
with client hints applied like we're
we're on a slow connection we're
applying
uh this philosophy to a site
so there's a lot of web fonts carousel
accordions and javascript to run it
run it all which is functionally
inaccessible on 2g
taking 90 seconds to load like 740ish k
but with client hints we can boil this
experience down to its core when
networks are slow or devices are slow
and for our trouble affected users will
have something that they can access more
quickly than the ideal experience we had
in mind it's like a compromise
you know all right there's a potential
you'll still get this ideal experience
but
otherwise if you can't accommodate that
we're going to boil this down for you
and if you want to learn more about
client hints you can check out this
guide i wrote for google web
fundamentals called adapting to users
with client hints
i also did a talk version of this last
year at full stack fest that just kind
of goes it's the play-by-play of this
article you can check it out
if it's something you're into the links
will be embedded in the slides when i
post them so
and so i'd like to close this talk on
what i think is a very important point
which is that we first need to figure
out what people
want from what we built for the web and
by that i mean like what purpose are we
trying to serve what tasks are we trying
to
enable people to accomplish and then we
need to work backward from there
and build something which serves that
purpose with precision and care that's
really important
don't try to get in people's way when
they need to do something simple
they need to like wire money to a friend
they need to
apply for public assistance or what if
it's somebody who
has been tossed out of their home by an
abusive partner and needs to like turn
to the web to find a place to find
shelter
those are the moments where we just need
to get out of our own way
and stop prioritizing our developer
experience
and help people because that's what part
partly that's what the web's for
to me the web is for more than just
buying [ __ ]
it's for helping people too so
regardless of our profession
craftspeople love their tools and as
developers we're really no different
we take pride in building great things
with the tools that we have
but unlike say the mechanic who fixes
your car the tools we use
can have a direct and felt impact when a
mechanic fixes your car he doesn't throw
all of his tools in your trunk
and you're carrying that weight around
but when we do the work a lot of times
the tools we use can kind of just end up
as baggage on the user experience
that they kind of have to carry around
we don't need to burden people with the
entire toolbox or even the entire tool
shed in some cases
sometimes it makes more sense to use
these smaller tools which are more
focused on the actual work
think alternatives like preact instead
of react which is a tenth of the size
but does pretty much
the same thing with the same api uh you
know alternatives to
moment.js or really anything that you've
used you use probably has an alternative
if it's popular enough your experience
i'll acknowledge this your experience as
a developer is important
but it is never more important than the
user's experience
and if your excitement for a certain set
of tools causes you to build things that
no longer efficiently serve the purpose
you set out to achieve
it's time to re-evaluate them and it's
my hope hope
that eventually we can come to find our
own ways of serving our collective
purpose with utilitarian precision
with the benefit for the benefit of all
who use the web
even and this might be a little
unpopular even if that's sometimes
that to get there we don't always need
javascript
thank you